NO REASON.
>> IT WAS ALL ABOUT KEEPING
CHILDREN OUT OF SCHOOLS.
WE ARE A GOING TO COPE HAMMERING
THIS.
>> Laura: EDUCATIONAL ENTITIES
WEREN'T JUST KEEPING KIDS OUT OF
SCHOOLS THEY WERE DISCOVERING
NEW WAYS TO POE LIEU THEIR
MINDS.
BREITBART REPORTING TEACHERS AND
TEE CUL STEWART AND RAFTIST IN
KINDERGARTEN AND DECUL TURING
THE MINDS OF SECOND GRADERS, THE
LEADING OF PRIVATE SCHOOLS SAW
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT SCHOOLS IS
INSTRUCTING EDUCATORS TO ADOPT
WHAT'S CALLED A RACE
ESSENTIALIST CURRICULUM FOR
CHILDREN.
ONE OF THEIR CHIEF INSTRUCTORS
IS A FORMER BLACK PANTHER.
>> THAT NOTION OF DIVERSITY THAT
WE REALLY REACHED OUT TO
INCLUDE, FOR INSTANCE, THE
DOMINATE CULTURE OF WHITE
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS, I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
REPRESENTATION IN WHAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE STUDYING ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO PRE K AND TALKING
ABOUT THINGS LIKE RACE, LIKE
GENDER, LIKE SOCIAL CLASS FOR
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS.
I THINK THE WHOLE NOTION OF
ASSESSING WITH AN EQUITY LENS IS
SO CRITICAL.
IT'S THERE THAT WE BEGIN TO SEE
THE BY AS DIFFERENCE.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS BOB WOODS
THE CEO AND FOUNDER OF THE WOODS
CENTER.
BOB, WE KEEP THINKING IT CAN'T
GET WORSE BUT NOW THEY'RE ALL
EXPOSING THEMSELVES.
YOUR TAKE ON THIS.
>> FIRST OF ALL THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON LAUREN.
THIS WHOLE EMPHASIS ON RACE, IT
REALLY IS THE, THE FLIP SIDE IS,
I THINK, WHITE PROGRESSIVE
NARCISSISM.
THAT SOMEHOW, THE DESTINY AND
FUTURE OF BLACK AMERICA IS
DEPENDING ON WHAT WHITE PEOPLE
DO OR DO NOT DO.
DR. KING REALLY WARNED AGAINST
THAT IN HER LETTER FROM A
BIRMINGHAM JAIL WHEN HE SAID THE
GREATEST STUMBLING BLOCK TO
WHITE PROGRESS IS NOT THE WHITE
COUNSEL OR THE KKK.
IT IS THE WHITE MODERATE.
THAT LUKEWARM ACCEPTANCE OF
PEOPLE IN GOOD WILL IS MORE
DIFFICULT TO TOLERATE THAN
OUTRIGHT REJECTION OF PEOPLE OF
ILL-WILL.
AND SOME OF THESE PROGRESSIVES
THAT ARE TEACHING THIS POISON TO
OUR CHILDREN, IN ONE SENSE, ARE
WORSE THAN BIGOTS.
THEY'RE WORSE THAN HARD LINED
BIGOTS BECAUSE THEY ARE REALLY
PREACHING SELF ANNIHILATION.
EVERY FIVE MINUTES, LAURA, A
CHILD IS SHOT IN AMERICA.
I KNOW OF A BLACK WOMAN WHO LOST
ALL FOUR OF HER CHILDREN, HER
FOUR SONS, TO HOMICIDE BEFORE
THE AGE OF 30.
THERE IS A CRISIS IN AMERICA,
AND THE ANSWER TO THOSE KIND OF
CHALLENGES IS NOT GOING TO COME
FROM TEACHING WHITE PEOPLE TO BE
LESS RACIST:  IT IS NARCISSISTIC
TO BELIEVE THAT BUT ALSO HARMFUL
TO THE NATION.
IT'S POISON US.
>> Laura: BOB.
>> I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ANOTHER
WHITE PERSON SAY TO ME I CANNOT
CONFRONT THIS TRUTH.
BOB WILSON, I'M WHITE, I CAN'T
SAY THAT, ONLY YOU CAN.
THAT'S CRAP.
WHITE AMERICA HAS TO SUMMON THE
COURAGE TO STAND UP AGAINST
THESE PROGRESSIVE BIGOTS.
>> Laura: WELL, BOB, WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS IN
RELATION -- OTHER SORRY TO
INTERRUPT BUT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS IF RELATION TO DISNEY
AND THAT'S MORE THE SEXUAL
PROPAGANDA I THINK BUT IT'S THIS
CORPORATE ENVIRONMENT THAT
THEY'RE HOISTING ON EMPLOYEES
WHERE IT'S THE EQUITY, DIVERSITY
EQUITY INCLUSION AGENDA WHICH ON
ITS FACE THAT SOUNDS FINE BUT
WHEN YOU DIG INTO IT, IT IS A
NOT ABOUT TOLERANCE.
THIS IS ABOUT YOU MUST BELIEVE,
YOU MUST THINK, AND IT JUST
CREATES AN INTOLERABLE
ENVIRONMENT FOR FREE THOUGHT AND
FREE EXPRESSION PERIOD, AND
LEARNING.
>> IT'S NOT ONLY INTOLERANCE BUT
IT'S INSULTING BUT THEY'RE USING
THE BLACK ISSUE ABOUT JUSTICE AS
THE REASON FOR THE NEED FOR IT.
AND I'M SAYING THAT THAT IS JUST
NO SHARED BY MAJORITY OF BLACK
AMERICANS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS.
HE WON BECAUSE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND LOW INCOME BLACK PEOPLE
VOTED FOR HIM.
HE ONLY WON BY 32,000 VOTES
BECAUSE OF HIS POSITION ON
EDUCATION.
>> Laura: BINGO.
>> EVEN THOUGH OBAMA AND OPRAH
WINFREY CAME IN TO CAMPAIGN FOR
GILLAM.
SO LOW-INCOME BLACK AMERICA DO
NOT SHARE THIS PASSION FOR
RACIAL DIVERSITY THAT IS BEING
THRUST ON THEM BY BLACK AND
WHITE ELITE.
>> Laura: YEAH, WHITE GUILT.
IT ALWAYS COMES BACK.
BOB WE'VE G